[Musique]
et on commence ces informations Gabriel
par la tempête Kiran qui a continuer de
toucher les ivelines aujourd'hui oui
Mathilde et la vigilance orange vent a
été levée ce matin dans les ivelines
mais les Rafal ont persisté jusqu'en
début d'après-midi entre 75 et 90 km/h
selon Météo France elle devrait se
poursuivre jusqu'en fin de journée
généralement inférieur à 85 km/h et plus
localisé par mesure de prévention arrêté
préfectoral a interdit l'accès au bois
et forêt du département toute la journée
certains parcs et jardins étaient
également interdit d'accès côté
transport le trafic a été complètement
interrompu dans certaines gares une
situation qui a contraint de nombreux
voyageurs à s'adapter du coup on est
forcé à prendre des uber ou des taxis
sauf que bah tout le monde se rabat sur
ça donc on est encore encore dans
l'attente ça fait depuis maintenan euh
je dirais 9h un peu moins même 8h3 9h
que j'attends et voilà après je sais
même pas s'il y a les bus aussi euh j'ai
entendu dire que c'était bondé donc je
m'y risque pas et moi je dois aller
vraiment sur Paris donc le travail c'est
ça exactement c'est pour le travail je
suis étudiant en alternance du
coup je suis un peu dans la dans le
stress alors la circulation devrait
rapidement revenir à la normale en
revanche consulter les réseaux sociaux
des modes de transport que vous
empruntez et finalement est-ce que la
tempête kyienne a fait des dégâts dans
les ivelines alors d'après le service
départemental d'incendie et de secours
des Yvelines il y a pas eu de dégâts
majeurs à noté majoritairement des
chutes d'arbres rapidement pris en
charge ào si ce sont des plaques
métallique d'un immeuble de nef étages
qui se sont envolés heureusement aucun
blessé n'est à déplorer la gendarmerie a
quant àelle recensé près de 200 appels à
7h ce matin contre une trentaine
d'habitude beaucoup d'interventions ont
eu lieu pour des chaussées obstrués on
poursuit ces informations Gabriel par un
nouveau commissariat qui doit voir le
jour à H encours oui situé au Parc des
Sports gu bon face les travaux du
nouveau commissariat viennent de
commencer il coordonnera notamment les
effectifs de trois commissariats de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline des innovations
technologiques qui seront déployées les
policiers auront accès à des drones pour
les situations de crise un stand de tir
virtuel ou encore un simulateur de
conduite sousension 18 mois de travaux
son sont à prévoir ouverture prévue
mathil de courant 2025 un peu de
football à présent on sait qui va
affronter ouille pour la 7e tour de la
Coupe de France il s'agit du dernier
club desvelin encore en list dans la
compétition oui le tirage au sort du 7e
tour de la Coupe de France a eu lieu ce
mardi 1er novembre à Claire Fontaine les
hommes de Michel Siani recevront anger
un club de Ligue 2 un gros tirage pour
ouille puisque le club évolue quatre
divisions en deous en Régionale 1 les
matchs se dérouleront le weekend du 18
et du 19 novembre on termine ces
informations Gabriel par un point trafic
puisqu'il va falloir s'armer de patience
ce weekend oui pour ce dernier weekend
de vacances de la tousin les vacanciers
seront nombreux dans le sens des retours
des difficultés de circulation sont
attendues vendredi et samedi
principalement sur les axes convergant
vers l'Île-de-France il est conseillé de
vous déplacer avant 14h selon les
dernières prévisions dimanche 5 novembre
tous les voyants sont auouvert pour le
moment et bien merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le #tag 7
news